so really we're on the brink i think of
a transformation
in the way science is done not only
tackling the problem of climate change
and and trying to find solutions but
also actually trying to understand the
system itself
so some of the technological um advances
that we
might be able to use to combat climate
change involve
the ability to generate energy in
sustainable ways
[Music]
the question today is can we make
solar panels or other materials
that are capable of generating energy
in useful ways in the past scientists
and engineers
have developed new materials but in
rather a haphazard way
thomas edison created the light bulb but
he developed
the original filament by testing
thousands of materials
to find eventually the one that worked
today we can use
machine learning and artificial
intelligence in our search for new
materials the reason
that we can do it better in the computer
is that the computer allows millions of
potential solutions to be searched
in ways that you couldn't do in the lab
[Music]
the reason that ai is important in the
development of our understanding of the
earth system
is that we're getting more and more data
about the earth
as time goes on so today we collect
satellite data
remote sensing observations allow us now
to look at the patterns of landslides
as climate is changing as weather
patterns change is the land being more
destabilized by excess water or are
there
are the erosion patterns in the
mountains changing
as climate changes
[Music]
extreme weather events as a result of
climate change
do appear to be on the increase but
there's another aspect to this
cities are getting bigger areas that
have always been vulnerable
to natural hazards with so many people
potentially at risk
it becomes important to understand the
system very quickly
examples include understanding the ways
in which
to respond to a situation where to send
the first responders which hospitals to
put on high alert
where to send relief supplies who needs
tents
so all of these sorts of disaster relief
processes
depend upon information
and we know as we travel around
congested cities
that we spend a lot of time sitting in
traffic
burning energy getting nowhere
autonomous vehicles provide
routes to making transport systems more
effective more efficient
so that you don't have these waves of
static
traffic on a motorway that everything is
moving at the right speed
and gets from one place to another in
the most effective way the most
efficient way
that's not something that as individuals
we're very good
at planning for ourselves so if we want
to reduce
recycle reuse can ai help us
well maybe but it depends upon our
motivation
ai is a tool it's not a master and so
our responses ultimately will depend
upon
our own personal motivations
and those of the society that we're part
of but ai and machine learning can help
us
move in the right direction thanks for
watching
if you enjoyed that be sure to check out
these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification
each time we upload a new video